y nos preguntan cuál es la constante de
proporcionalidad en la ecuación 4 y 8 x
pausa en el vídeo e inténtenlo bien tal
vez estamos acostumbrados a ver
constantes de proporcionalidad pero en
las que tenemos ecuaciones escritas de
una forma un poco diferente una
constante de proporcionalidad es ese
algo por lo que necesitamos multiplicar
x para obtener que entonces que es igual
a nuestra constante de proporcionalidad
por equis pero esta ecuación no está
escrita de esta forma así que lo que
podemos hacer es manipularla un poco
para que podamos verla de esta manera y
para eso necesitamos despejar y vamos a
ver inicialmente tenemos cuatro y es
igual a 8x así que para despejar y
simplemente podemos dividir ambos lados
entre 4 y así nos queda que es igual a 8
entre 4
2 x x ahora si podemos identificar
fácilmente la constante de
proporcionalidad podemos ver que para
obtener que necesitamos multiplicar x
por 2 esta es nuestra constante de
proporcionalidad hagamos otro ejemplo
aquí nos preguntan qué ecuación tiene
una constante de proporcionalidad igual
a un medio nuevamente pausa en el vídeo
y traten de resolverlo ok vamos a
analizar ecuación por ecuación y
calcularemos sus constantes de
proporcionalidad para ver cuál tiene una
constante igual a un medio en la opción
a claramente podemos ver que tenemos una
constante de proporcionalidad de un
octavo así que esta no es la ecuación ve
claramente tiene una constante de
proporcionalidad de 4 no de un medio la
descartamos ahora para la constante de
proporcionalidad en la ecuación c si
queremos despejar
podemos dividir ambos lados entre 6 y
nos queda que ya es
igual a 3 sextos por equis y eso es lo
mismo que un medio por equis aquí
tenemos la constante de proporcionalidad
de un medio esta es la opción que
elegiremos finalmente podemos verificar
que esta opción tampoco es válida si
queremos despejar
necesitamos dividir ambos lados entre 3
y así nos queda que que es igual a 9
entre 3 que es 3x así que en este caso
la constante de proporcionalidad es 3
por lo tanto nuestra respuesta es la
opción c este es el final del vídeo